IDO GREEN: Welcome to another
episode of GDL Israel.
Today we have Nissim
Betito with us.
Thank you for coming and
joining, of course.
NISSIM BETITO: Thank you.
IDO GREEN: And without further
ado, we promise you that we
jump into what ChromeOS is
basically allowing developers
and hackers, in the
current state.
Quite different, the world
that we have today
from pixel to others.
And how you could basically
develop and write code when
you're using Chromebook.
So there are two or three
slides that we prepared.
Let's share them.
And first and foremost, it's
quite clear that today with
all the movement to the cloud
we see more and more IDEs
basically allowing you
great functionality.
And lets you be productive when
you're working with your
Chromebook.
Cloud9, ShiftEdit, Neutron
Drive, all of them are working
with Google Drive.
Some of them are a nice
integration with Dropbox.
And Cloud9, for instance, is
letting you work with GitHub.
Repositories.
So it's very easy and very
straightforward to work with,
when you have your Chromebook.
Let me try and basically share
with you my Cloud9
environment.
And as you can see, I already
installed it.
So you can see that I have the
option to launch the app from
Chrome Web Store.
And basically when I'm launching
the app, I have here
a nice dashboard that
I could open.
And because we don't have too
much time, I'll just open
immediately a project
that I already did.
Now the beauty here is that
the project is hosted on
GitHub, so if you want to have
nice collaboration with your
teammates you could
definitely do so.
And here in the file, you have a
full blown IDE that lets you
use your keyboard with nice
shortcuts, for people that are
used to different IDEs.
And with some nice things that
are suggesting how to improve
and make our code
more readable.
Of course you could run it later
on, and there are some
very, very cool capabilities
that Cloud9 specifically
letting you know.
Using HTML5 client side offline
APIs from file, to
local storage, to IndexedDB.
And it's quite nice to see how
they're leveraging it.
Other options, and quite a lot
of options that you can see
here, are some that are hosted
on Google Cloud.
Some are not.
And we highly encourage you just
to check and see what is
the best tool to accomplish
your job.
So one option is just to take
and use a current IDE that you
have out there.
But for the ones that want to
hack a little bit more and
feel what ChromeOS looks like,
we do have the options to run
ChromeOS in VirtualBox.
And actually in VMware
as well.
So we'll put this slide
up there after
we finish the show.
But you have your link to a
blog post that I wrote,
actually now it's almost
two years--
a year and a half.
And basically it lets you test
drive ChromeOS in VirtualBox.
Quite nice, and you could
get the feeling of
how it looks like.
And what things you
could do with it.
Other good option for people
that like to hack with
hardware is to install ChromeOS
on the SD card.
And then run it side by side
with your Chromebooks.
For instance you could install
Ubuntu or any other version of
Linux on the SD card, and have
the ability to work on
ChromeOS with the online IDEs.
Or just launch and have another
operation system that
is installed on the
Chromebook.
And if it's-- in our case,
we'll show you Ubuntu--
you have everything there from
Java to LAMP, Apache, MySQL,
all the things that you want.
And [? at the end of
the day it's ?]
Ubuntu.
So you could go and get
pretty wild with it.
For the brave ones, you could
just install side by side the
operations system and have a
full blown dual boot machine.
Or just install [INAUDIBLE].
So the last thing is that of
course before you are going
and want to hack your
Chromebook, you must enter
development mode.
The good thing about it
is that you will be
able to exit it.
So you won't ruin your
Chromebook in
case things are scary.
How to enter development mode.
So are the three steps.
But we'll put the first links
that just elaborate and show
you exact step by step what
you need to do in
order to enter it.
After you enter the development
mode, there are a
few steps that basically pull
from GitHub and operations
that customize citron that
lets you run Ubuntu on
Chromebook.
And how you do it and how it
looks like, we'll just let
Nissim explain to us how
we did this magic.
So let's stop the
screen sharing.
And do you want to
move the camera?
OK, first explain, and then.
OK.
NISSIM BETITO: Yeah.
So hey guys.
In the end the main goal is to
just, at least as I prefer to
do, a side by side
installation.
That way you know that
you don't damage your
hardware in any way.
And then it's an easy way to
create if you like to develop
or to use it for all kinds of
purpose to create an SD card.
It's really cheap.
You're just creating
all kinds of Ubuntu
flavor on your SD card.
What we have here today
is a [INAUDIBLE]
machine.
The Samsung I5 Chromebook.
I already turned it on to
the development mode.
And I changed that.
And if they will hold the
camera for a second.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
I'll take the camera out.
And we'll just flip, and
see the nice views.
NISSIM BETITO: So I inserted the
SD card into the laptop.
In the end what we are going
to do after developer mode.
If I turn the machine you can
see the screen that is showing
us that we are in
developer mode.
If we leave it like that it will
just start booting and go
to a kind of ChromeOS
questioning mode.
It will give you the option to
install your OS or to change
the version that you
are running.
But by pressing Control U on
the machine, it's basically
giving the OS the command to
change to a different SD card
boot [? mode. ?]
IDO GREEN: We'll try to capture
that now the loading
script is on.
NISSIM BETITO: So exactly from
this step and on what we have
here is a regular Linux boot
mode that in a sec you will
see the Ubuntu 12.4
booting up.
And in that distribution that we
installed, we installed the
full Ubuntu OS straight
from the repository
that we have online.
You have LibreOffice.
You have the regular stuff
that comes with Ubuntu.
It's recognizing your Wi-Fi,
your OS, graphic card.
Everything.
All the basic things that you
need for a Linux device.
As you can see we have Unity
running and presenting.
And we have also Chrome
on the machine.
IDO GREEN: So now we're running
Chrome inside ChromeOS.
NISSIM BETITO: Exactly.
IDO GREEN: Nice.
Nice.
NISSIM BETITO: Few things that
I would recommend you to do
is, probably play little
bit with Linux.
If you want to try
it just move some
packages you don't need.
Or maybe just, in the end, take
a flavor that you know
that you can develop on, and
play, as you would use to do
on a regular laptop.
And again, this is Chromebook.
So it's very simple to go back,
as Ido said, to get out
from developer mode and
just to get back to
your original ChromeOS.
And it's so beautiful
that it's fast.
It's at the press of a button.
And you don't need to do get any
special CD installation or
any other hardware to just
do these changes.
So as Ido said, it's
three simple steps.
Change to developer mode.
Insert your SD card and
recognize it in your laptop.
I tried at least a few SD
cards and USB dumps.
And ChromeOS and Chromebooks
basically
recognized all of them.
And just captured the image from
online and just throw it
on your SD card.
IDO GREEN: Now the good tip here
is to use SD card that
has at least 8 gig, right.
NISSIM BETITO: Exactly.
IDO GREEN: So it will have
a bit more memory.
And the other thing that you
need to remember is that it's
all without any warranty.
NISSIM BETITO: Yeah.
IDO GREEN: So you're downloading
scripts from the
web, put your best judgement
into place and make sure that
it's not a production laptop.
NISSIM BETITO: Exactly, yeah.
IDO GREEN: Another cool thing
that we'll show you in the
near future is what you did
with this little guy.
NISSIM BETITO: Yes, we have the
Raspberry Pi here with us.
And then another thing that we
tried also was running just
ChromeOS on Raspberry Pi.
It's basically ARM based
board that you have an
HDMI video in it.
And also doing network ports.
You have two USB ports only
and one network port.
You can do anything with it.
You can, as we did with the
Chromebook, just pushed an SD
card with Ubuntu flavor, we
can do the same thing with
Raspberry Pi but just with
ChromeOS on the Raspberry.
It's beautiful.
Again you have the SD slot.
So you can create as few
distribution and as much
distribution that you want
for any kind of software
development or installation that
you need in your office,
at home, or whatever
you need to.
And as Ido said, probably if you
want we can talk about it
a little bit more
in the future.
And even show you
how it's done.
IDO GREEN: Yeah definitely.
And I think that the main
feedback that you gave was
that it was much slower than the
Chromebook itself, right.
NISSIM BETITO: Yes.
IDO GREEN: In terms of
the capabilities.
NISSIM BETITO: [INAUDIBLE]
yes.
IDO GREEN: But yeah, it's very,
very cool and of course,
much cheaper.
NISSIM BETITO: Yeah.
IDO GREEN: Great.
So I think I will wrap
it up for this time.
We are extremely busy and have
lot of surprises for you for
next week at Google I/O. So for
the ones that aren't going
to be live there, just feel
free to watch the live
Hangouts, and the broadcast
that we'll of course have,
like we do every year.
And until two weeks' time,
because next week we aren't
going to have our weekly show,
be strong and safe.
Thank you.
NISSIM BETITO: Bye guys.
IDO GREEN: Bye-bye.